[Music]
wynn is with us in houston texas hi
welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave thanks for taking my call how
are you better than i deserve how can we
help
awesome hi um i'm a 25 year old single
guy i grew up in texas went to college
got a master's in accounting
and then after college i got a great job
and moved to new york city for about a
year um when coveted hit and i was a
part of that group that blessing in
disguise kind of escaped the city and
migrated back to my parents where i've
been
saving and working remotely
and just saving really
and so i don't have a lot of expenses
and i've
put up about 45 000 in my 401k
um in addition to
kind of 23 000 just sitting in a bank
account
um and i'm looking to move back and so
my question is
um what do i do with that extra money is
it worth buying a rental property in
somewhere like houston where i can
maybe one day move back and i can be
making a little bit of rental income on
the side or should i just park it in a
ira or mutual fund while i pay for rent
in new york because i can't afford real
estate in new york so you're going to be
renting in new york and you're wondering
should i buy some property for fun as a
rental in texas with this uh money use
it as a down payment
and then maybe move back into that
property one day in five ten years
well
you may need a little more than that i
don't know what the i mean you're in the
houston area
correct
yeah i mean you're a young guy and i
feel like you're not sure where life's
gonna take you i don't think rental
property is a bad idea and you may turn
that into a primary residence one day
but i just think there's a lot of life
ahead of you and i don't know that
you know this is where you want to plant
it right now with that chunk of change
yeah two problems one is you're getting
ready to go into debt on the rental
property and two um it's gonna be long
distance rental so if i'm in your shoes
i'm not doing it for those two reasons
i'm just gonna rent in new york for a
little while and pile up cash continue
to pile up cash until you figure out
what your long-term game plan is
somehow i don't think you're in new york
city for 25 years
yeah i don't think you're there yeah and
when you come back to houston or back to
wherever you choose to come quote back
to texas tennessee whatever it is
that is when you would buy in that
market and by then you'd have a really
really good pile of cash you might even
pay cash for your first house i'd love
that if you were if you did that that's
a possibility but no i would not own
long-distance rental property and i
would not go in debt to do it two
reasons to stay away from that sounds
kind of cool sounds kind of fun
until the renter doesn't